foreign
that was quick I am resigning Liz truss
makes history for the shortest most
chaotic tenure as British prime minister
and let us rejoice a comedy that comes
from political crisis we need satire
the race to be BC's next Premier becomes
a one-man show why the only other
Contender was disqualified
emotional final farewell
two Ontario police officers are laid to
rest
National with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
they say a week is a long time in
politics in the UK that could be
shortened to just a day the country is
about to get yet another prime minister
24 hours ago Liz truss said she was a
fighter not a quitter today she quit
since trust took over the Tory party in
early September and met the late Queen
Elizabeth it has all been downhill her
plan for billions in unfunded tax cuts
backfired rejected by the markets and
her own party causing the pound to crash
threatening the stability of the country
her own political future reduced to
ridicule one tabloid setting up this
webcam and asking will Liz truss Outlast
this lettuce
[Music]
well the answer was a resounding no
today the lettuce rejoiced in the end it
was the Tory party who ousted trust
they'd anointed her after the party
kicked out Boris Johnson in July well
tonight his name is back in the news in
what is an extraordinary revolving door
of Tory Prime Ministers our Crystal
demanding begins our coverage tonight
from London Crystal
Donna people are calling the political
upheaval here in the UK everything from
calamitous disastrous even an utter
shame you would think after nearly a
thousand years British Parliament would
have seen everything but this is a first
Liz trust took power touting her bold
economic plan to grow the economy she
leaves admitting she was ineffective we
set out a vision for a low tax
high-growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
her political downfall comes just six
weeks after her government's mini-budget
tanked markets featuring sweeping
trickle-down tax reforms with breaks for
the wealthy it was pitched with little
explanation as to how it would be
financed
the British Tories chose her as their
leader only in September but trust never
enjoyed deep support from her colleagues
or the public Mr Speaker
I am a fighter and not a quitter a day
later
she accepted her fate I am resigning as
leader of the conservative party
reaction has been robust whoever
replaces her to act on the climate
crisis the cost of living and the energy
crisis we need a general election
because it's just a cycle of rubbish and
they replace rubbish with more rubbish
but you know what they say about one
man's trash hasta la vista baby thank
you Boris Johnson himself resigned and
said goodbye under a cloud of hostility
and Scandal but he is one name being
floated as a possible nominee as is
Rishi sunak the candidate pushed aside
just last month in favor of trusts
candidates need the backing of 100 MPS
in order to be considered well it's an
absolute disgrace
um you know it makes you wonder where
they should vote conservative again this
country's seen so much instability over
the last couple years
Crystal Liz trust didn't have a mandate
from the people she was chosen by the
party the last Tory leader to win an
election a majority is Boris Johnson
could he really make a comeback
well Donna given what we've seen over
the last couple of months no one is
ruling anything out Boris Johnson is out
of the country on holiday so we haven't
heard from him directly but he has his
supporters so many people including
voters are saying they want Boris back
now it is worth mentioning he is still
facing an investigation by the
Parliamentary standards committee
because potentially that he misled
Parliament and he resigned because there
was a party Revolt a record number of
ministers and MPS resigned saying that
he was unfit now who will lead the party
we don't have to wait that long to find
out who the next prime minister will be
at the earliest we could know on Monday
when the nominations closed at the
latest we'll find out on Friday who the
next prime minister will be Donna right
crystal gemancing in London thanks well
the race is underway to choose a new
prime minister but the political crisis
in the UK has left the country almost
completely paralyzed at a time when
there is real economic turmoil and a
lack of faith in public institutions not
only there but across the world the days
of cool Britannia and being a model of
stability are gone now as Eric Sorensen
reports Britain is giving the world a
lesson in what not to do
our country will be stronger if we stay
almost a decade ago conservative Prime
Minister David Cameron promised a
referendum to unite his party his
country and remain in the EU it led to
just the opposite brexit and out he went
I expect to go to the palace and offer
my resignation I will shortly leave the
job that a Theresa May fared no better
and by the time Boris Johnson took over
the party embraced brexit deliver brexit
Johnson was a great salesman but brexit
built on misleading promises led to
headaches with trade and travel migrant
workers and labor shortages and the
Irish Border the UK emerged from the
pandemic less resilient than its former
EU Partners over three years the
Eurozone economy grew almost 2 percent
while the UK economy shrank in the G7
the U.S and Canada led the way the UK at
the bottom the only G7 country with a
smaller GDP than before covid-19
party spectacularly failed because of
the Tories because of brexit the UK has
become politically Italy without the the
weather or the food Britain a global
leader in finance the conservatives a
reputation for fiscal management but
amid rampant inflation Liz trust pushed
tax cuts that only fueled more inflation
do you feel like you've been betrayed by
the Prime Minister Global confidence
crumbled her Chancellor of the
ex-chequer was forced out and soon trust
herself was gone
in just six years the UK conservatives
have cycled through four Prime Ministers
soon to be five a breathtaking political
turnover even Tories are appalled one
telling the BBC it is pitiful reflection
on the conservative parliamentary party
at every level in a time of global
tension allies yearn for that UK
steadiness to return it is
important for Britain to regain
political stability said Francis
Emmanuel macron that's all I want with
conservative popularity disintegrating
this man the labor party's Kier starmer
is now favored to win the next election
this is not just a soap opera at the top
of the Tory party it's doing huge damage
to our economy and to the reputation of
our country starmer may not get the
quick election he wants but his message
is resonating economic credibility God
Eric Sorensen Global News
you're in Canada British Columbia is
getting a new premier the province's
former Attorney General David EBY the
process has not been without controversy
after weeks of discussion the BC NDP
voted to disqualify EB's only opponent
nitu garcha is following this story for
us nitu
Donna this has been quite the political
storm today outgoing Premier John Horgan
was asked why the list of bcndp
executive members who voted to
disqualify Angelia Pottery isn't being
made public and he was clearly
frustrated over what he calls harassment
by the BC green party take a listen
why because they're being inundated by
people who say this is this is by green
party members saying we want to take
over your party I'm sure you can find
their names on the website if you want
their addresses and phone numbers and
emails you're going to have to do
something else not talk to me I think
I'm done here thanks very much everybody
thanks everyone I'll see you around
[Music]
that is how what was perhaps his final
news conference as BC's Premier ended
here's how the party got to this point
after nearly four hours 40 members of
the BC NDP executive decided to
disqualify Angelia Pottery members
across the country have spoken up on
Twitter
urging the provincial executive to let
the leader of the next the next leader
of the bcndp be chosen by members not
decided behind closed doors the 32 year
old climate activist who's never held
office was trying to pull off an upset
when she joined the campaign to become
the next leader of BC hold Colonial
structure the only other candidate for
the top job front-runner David EBY the
46 year old lawyer and former Attorney
General who entered the bid with the
near unanimous support of his caucus
said he's focused on his campaign simply
because this leadership race is over
does not mean that the issue of climate
change goes away uh and I know that was
a huge priority for her after a pottery
quickly gained so much member support
many thought the politically
unbelievable could actually happen she
threatened to derail Evie's acclimation
as NDP leader a potterized bid was
halted late Wednesday night with the
party brass claiming she improperly used
third parties for her membership Drive
including a non-profit called Dogwood
describing itself as VC's largest
non-partisan citizen action Network upon
a ride saying the rules were changed and
applied to her campaign retroactively
Premier John Horgan announced in June he
was stepping down mid-term kick-starting
the race at a news conference Thursday
he said he offers his full support to
the last remaining candidate in the
leadership race I am confident that the
work of the table officers and the
executive the bcndp have been thorough
the controversy highly damaging to the
party in charge of what had been one of
the most stable provincial governments
in Canada
and with a pottery out David EBY will be
declared leader tomorrow before he's
sworn in at a later date as questions
grow over whether it's time for
elections BC to start supervising these
party leadership races Donna all right
nathu Garcia in Burnaby BC thanks a top
intelligence officer with the Ontario
Provincial Police says his Force did not
find any evidence the so-called Freedom
protest in Ottawa earlier this year was
a national security threat OPP
superintendent Pat Morris testified
today at the public inquiry reviewing
the federal government's decision to
invoke the emergencies act David Akin
reports on what he and other officers
had to say
is it fair to say that at no point
during the Convoy protest did you
receive reliable intelligence that would
lead you to conclude that there was a
risk to National Security that would
rise above the the Potential Threat to
National Security that you identified in
that report that's correct Ontario
Provincial Police Superintendent Bill
Morris confirmed that Convoy protesters
in Ottawa and elsewhere in the province
had the potential to be a threat but
they did not find evidence of violence
caused by extremism everybody was asking
about extremism
we weren't seeing much evidence of it
that could be important testimony since
the federal government cited threats to
National Security by potential violent
extremists as one of the reasons it
invoked the emergencies act on February
the 14th but one of the most senior
Ottawa police officers to take the stand
so far testify that the powers police
were given as a result of the federal
emergencies act helped clear the protest
yes I think it assisted I would say
greased the wheels of the plan that we
had in place among other things the
emergencies act gave police the power to
commandeer tow trucks and Ottawa Police
put those in other powers to use the
emergencies Act made us more confident
in in the approach we were taking and
enabled us to
um you know get get past the issues of
whether it was the seizing of assets I
think that was helpful in terms of
setting a tone for some of the people
who may be deterred by that still under
cross-examination by lawyers
representing those who thought the
invocation of the emergencies Act was
not warranted
ottawa's deputy chief conceded that the
powers given to police under that act
were quote useful but not necessary
Donna all right David thanks there are
some new developments from the inquiry
into the Nova Scotia mass shootings
audio recordings of a phone call between
RCMP commissioner Brenda lucky and the
Nova Scotia RCMP have been released
conversations that might hold a link to
allegations the liberal government
interfered in the investigation to try
to advance its agenda on gun control
Ross Lord has more on this tonight Ross
Donna we only have partial transcripts
and recordings of commissioner Lucky's
notorious meeting with Nova Scotia RCMP
Personnel but they do include several
references to government officials both
commissioner lucky and then Public
Safety Minister Bill Blair denied there
was political interference but the
contents of her phone call with Nova
Scotia mounties suggests there was
regular contact lucky has acknowledged
being frustrated and used release from
Nova Scotia RCMP excluded details of the
port-au-pic Killer's weapons she denies
allegations that she was crossing
ethical boundaries and trying to boost
public support for the government's gun
control agenda there was a request that
I got
from The Minister's office and I shared
with the minister that that in fact it
was going to be in the uh in the news
release and it wasn't as Nova Scotia
mounties and Lucky's own Communications
staffers explain how chaotic their jobs
became after the massacre lucky makes
another reference suggesting they let
down the government not being able to
come through for the minister
um on on the simplest of requests
commissioner lucky also expressed
frustration that there was not a
detailed timeline of the massacre
released sooner because she was eager to
provide it for the Prime Minister before
he heard it through the media Donna all
right Ross Lord in Halifax thank you
next the demands for answers over the
shocking suggestions made to a veteran
suffering in silence
[Music]
Canada's veterans affairs minister is
before a committee today related to a
shocking story Global News broke in
August a Canadian forces veteran seeking
treatment for post-traumatic stress
disorder was offered medical assistance
in dying today was the first time the
minister Lawrence McCauley talked
publicly about what happened Mercedes
Stevenson was listening Mercedes
Donna a veteran came forward to us at
global news after a Veterans Affairs
employee offered him as you mentioned
medical assistance in dying as an
alternative to treating his PTSD and
traumatic brain injury he suffered in
Afghanistan the veteran told us that it
was raised out of nowhere and repeatedly
by the employee and that he felt
pressured the VAC employee also
mentioned helping another veteran with
maid that launched an investigation into
whether this was a systemic problem at
committee Minister Lawrence McCauley
condemned what happened but often seemed
to shunt responsibility to his
Department as the opposition demanded
answers
when we're talking about a situation
where a veteran comes crying for help to
Veterans Affairs and is instead
suggested that maybe you should consider
killing yourself
that's to me sounds like it should be a
high priority to deal with but this was
a mistake and it was wrong and it was
unacceptable and whatever word she could
use it's totally wrong in every way but
what you do when you when this comes up
is that you put a training program in
place it will probably include more than
that but that's not the field that I
mean I'm to make sure that this is
properly investigated dealt with
now when it comes to that investigation
Macaulay says that this was an isolated
incident but it's not clear how that's
been determined when the department says
the investigation is still ongoing so
far they found no other examples the
employee in question is still working at
vac but no longer has direct contact
with veterans employees have also been
told they cannot raise made but feelings
of betrayal cut deeply in the veteran
community and concern about death by
Suicide among veterans makes this an
issue that is just that much more
painful Donna Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you
Headley frontman Jacob hogard has been
granted bail as he appeals a conviction
for sexual assault earlier today the
singer was sentenced to five years in
prison for sexually assaulting a woman
in a Toronto hotel room in 2016. hogard
was previously found not guilty of
sexual assault causing bodily harm
related to the case of a teenaged fan
heartbreaking goodbyes coming up the
funeral for two Ontario police officers
two Ontario police officers killed in
the line of duty last week were laid to
rest today foreign
[Music]
funeral attended by close family
dignitaries police and emergency service
personnel
Constable Morgan Russell was a 33-year
veteran with his South Simcoe police
Constable Devin Northrup spent six years
with the fourth Force both are being
remembered as respected members of the
community who embodied Integrity courage
and compassion and their families say
they had the biggest hearts
the time we did have together was pure
joy
with more happiness and love than every
anyone will ever know I will love you
forever
and you are my hero I pray that no one
else has to go through this
I wish I still had him here but I'm so
lucky to have had him for 25 years
I love you Daddy forever
the two officers were fatally shot
October 11th while responding to a call
in the small town of Innisfil Ontario
let us rejoice next finding comedy gold
in the UK political crisis
[Music]
it's not polite to laugh at others
Misfortune but laugh at yourself well
the British are doing a lot of that
right now along with a lot of swearing
and lots of head shaking the political
crisis in the UK is serious business of
course but satirists and comedians are
making the most of it especially that
Victorious head of lettuce Heather
York's West takes a look at the lighter
side of the political turmoil
this is beginning
let us rejoice with a veggie Victorious
the British public can only remain calm
and try turning over a new Leaf social
media users have had a field day with a
situation as chaotic and nonsensical as
this we need satire first degree the
coping mechanism because the news itself
has been a little bananas it has been a
night of astonishing scenes at
Westminster the deputy chief whip was
reported to have left the scene saying
I'm absolutely effing Furious I just
don't effing care anymore before he
resigned that's the night late news
right now the headlines echoing
everywhere here's Germany
I'm [ __ ] furious and I don't [ __ ]
care anymore as a satirist you use
absurdity to point out what's actually
happening but when what's actually
happening is so absurd that you can't
out absurd it it does become a bit of a
challenge it can be hard to tell truth
from satire these days Liz trust resigns
after long illustrious Reign of Power
spanning two monarchs while memes like
these flood social feeds social media
has been on fire hasn't it I mean this
is something that our Spirits do best
it's always been a way of kind of
tackling very serious issues through
comedy
um and of course if you actually look at
it it's not really funny it's the old
expression I mean if you're not laughing
you're crying and I think as every day
there is more and more to be upset about
and worried about if you can find some
catharsis in comedy then that's amazing
who gets the last laugh not trusses
biographers their book on her rise to
power isn't out for another six weeks
Heather your ex West Global News
that's global national for this Thursday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is McGill University in Montreal we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to us and thanks for watching Farah NASA
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow and
I'll see you Saturday for the new
reality bye-bye
[Music]